[Music]
but first I want to say thank you so
much to the organizers here it was
really great working with you and I
think that you have a really amazing
conference today I'm really excited to
be my first time speaking in Poland my
grandfather was polish I know I'm so
American when I say that but my
grandfather was polish and I think that
he would be proud if he was still with
us today I'm gonna be talking about
reliable models most of the time I work
in NLP so we're gonna see some NLP
examples I'm really excited with how
much NLP talks we have today and I'm
actually going to touch on some things
that I think will be repeated throughout
the different talks that you hear today
and tomorrow
Oh Linux okay so we're gonna start off
with a joke other than the Linux joke
we're gonna start off with the machine
learning joke so who here works with
machine learning excellent you're my
target audience so apologies to anybody
else here but I don't know if you follow
xkcd it's my favorite my favorite
webcomic and I don't know if you saw
this machine learning comic already but
I'll give you a chance to read it if not
I had a good laugh with it
and yeah you know I think we can have a
good chuckle I think especially probably
the machine learning practitioners in
the room can have a good chuckle with
this because sometimes you know my mom
or something asked me what I do and I
think it sounds like this and it might
even sound like a really confused
version of this so for those of you that
are experts of course or that are
researchers it's far more complex than
this and I know that and I understand it
and there's plenty of great people in
the room that are doing interesting work
and research with machine learning but
the problem is is that the ability for
the average person even let's say the
average person with some basic math and
statistics to understand what's
happening particularly when we talk
about these deep learning systems it's
difficult right and my fear is that our
world our world of machine learning and
data science will become so separated
from the average person's ability to
understand what's happening that we will
essentially specialize ourselves into
oblivion and we will essentially become
so specialized expert technical elite
we've been seeing how that's been
working out in the elections that have
occurred in the past few years that if
you separate yourself so much and if the
average person sees you as some sort of
elite that's not answerable to any
single person then that's really easy to
set yourself up for failure and what I
want is a long without another AI winter
growth of our space and the science in
our space and I think to do so that we
need to think about interpretability
not only for the conversations that we
have with one another but especially for
the conversations that we have with
other people who want to maybe learn or
start using machine learning and yet
this is how it looks so that's one good
reason why we care about
interpretability but I also have some
other reasons the first and foremost in
my opinion is the ability for area
experts or your user to understand and
interact with your models so we have how
many people here are area
experts in what they're actually
building machine learning on like you
okay very rare right and that's really
neat when you have that insight I think
that when you talk to somebody who's an
area expert and they're doing machine
learning within their own field of
expertise they have a lot of insight and
they can understand what's happening and
they can figure out better ways to
generalize their models but
unfortunately most of us are experts in
mathematics or statistics or physics or
whatever your background is and instead
we're working with areas that we may or
may not have a background in and if we
can't communicate clearly to the area
experts and ask them why is this failing
why does this rationale make sense or
does not make sense then we can't also
grow from their feedback so here is a
shorter quote of which I'll read a
longer one Tommy yeah Kula is a
professor at MIT working on
interpretability there's a broader
aspect to this work as well you may not
want to just verify that the model is
making the prediction in the right way
you might also want to exert some
influence in terms of the types of
predictions that it should make how does
a layperson communicate with a complex
model that's trained with algorithms
that they know nothing about they might
be able to tell you about the rationale
for a particular prediction in that
sense it opens up a different way of
communicating with the model and I think
that that really resonated with me how
do we allow users and area experts to
give and explain rationales to us so we
can build a better model right this is
feedback that we need this is labeling
that we need and if we make it so
complex that we can't talk with someone
about it then we're gonna have some
serious issues later when it doesn't
generalize well or when it's learned
something that we didn't intend for it
to learn and this goes into GD P R so GD
P R is the general data protection
regulation that will be coming into play
in all of the EU in May of 2018 and I
have a longer post and talked about this
and what it means for us as data
scientists but I think it's important
us to think about and talk about now I'm
not a lawyer I know nothing about law
really so I'm not here to talk with you
about compliance what I'm here to talk
with you about is some of the intention
behind the regulation from being a lay
person who's read through things and
talked with and read a few legal papers
on the subject article 13 is often
referenced in this quote/unquote right
to an explanation you might have heard
the right to an explanation you might
have heard people really being
fear-mongering about it but I would say
it's less of a right to an explanation
and it's more of a right for the user to
be informed how their personal data is
going to be used and article 13 says the
controller which is any of us that use
personal data says the controller shall
at the time when personal data are
obtained provide the data subject with
the following further information it
goes through a series of points of which
one is the existence of automated
decision-making meaningful information
about the logic involved as well as the
significance and the envisaged
consequences of such processing for the
data subject what does this mean this
means that if I'm a user and you're
using my personal data now we can define
what that means or doesn't mean but
you're using my personal data to make
some automated decision learning about
me some automated machine learning that
may affect my life may affect my use on
your site may even affect what ads I'm
shown but it also might affect something
like whether I get a bank loan or it
might affect something like whether my
doctor recommends treatment or not this
is something that I have a right to know
about and this is something that I have
a right to have access to some
information of how that algorithm works
or how that data or decision was reached
so this is something we should can be
concerned about and if we're using
something that's very very
uninterpretable we might have an issue
explaining things and we might have an
issue in terms of transparency and I
think if we're concerned about
transparency then maybe we should think
about why we're so concerned are we
concerned about trying
Farren see because perhaps we are a bit
ashamed with what our machine learning
is doing or perhaps what we're doing we
would classify as unethical or immoral
as people and if so maybe we should at
least think about that
finally models can learn unintended
stereotypes or biases from our world
so models as we've seen and shown these
are from the Google News vectors these
are the Google News vectors used with
Jensen and what we can see is that man
is - woman as computer programmer is -
homemaker we can also see that some
vectors that are nearby Mexicans are
illegals and illegal aliens and other
things I did a longer exploration of
this of which I have a write-up on it
but I would say that there is definitely
pornographic content in the Google news
vectors and there's probably some other
unintended side effects that you don't
necessarily want to use as a basis for
your deep learning language model so if
you're just using the word to vet Google
news vectors and retraining the top
layer perhaps you might need to think
about what that unintended effect on
your chat bite bot might have that
perhaps maybe you don't want your chat
bot using these types of stereotypes in
their interactions with users on your
website or in your app whatever it is
there's quite a good paper on this and
it's by Arvind Narayan on Johanna Bryson
and Alan Collison and it explores some
of the stereotypes that are easily found
in the news vectors that Google released
and several other vector spaces even
when you use glove training on the same
data so clearly there's some reasons for
interpretability and one of them that
final one is perhaps finding those types
of issues in your data before your user
or a researcher or somebody else does so
moving forward we want to create
interpretable models how can we go about
doing so
I'm here to share with you some of the
ways that we possibly can but by no
means is this a closed space so we're
also going to talk about the challenges
and we're going to talk about research
that is open and welcome for you to
participate in the initial stage that we
need to do is define what
interpretability or explain explainable
models means in our space or to our
users
so interpretability can mean a very
different thing if it's simply your team
of data scientists that needs to
interpret and understand and talk with
one another how the model is operating
and it can mean something completely
different
if the interpretability is an end user
that has no experience or background in
statistics so what we have here is a
great quote and I thought that it was
relevant from a paper that'll refer to a
few times which is called why should I
trust you
and these researchers they're based at
the University of Washington and they've
released actually an open-source Python
library to help interpret your models
and they define interpret ability in a
explanation really the notion of
interpret ability also depends on the
target audience machine learning
practitioners may be able to interpret
small Bayesian networks but laymen or
lay women may be more comfortable with a
small number of weighted features as an
explanation and we're gonna dive a
little bit into this but you need to
define it for your use case so if your
use case is that you only need to you
only need to explain interpretability
with your co-workers then you can
probably make a much more complex model
and I would say go for it if your
explain ability needs to be for some end
user or for a banker or a police officer
or something else then maybe you need to
think about how to best convey that to
your user and start building or using
the algorithms that are already
available from cognitive cognitive
science to say okay is this
understandable for a human and there's
quite a lot of research already in this
space so that same paper
is the paper that introduced lime now
they have two papers and they have an
open-source Python library and Lima is
called local interprete Balma no
explanations and what it is to do is it
aims to explore local interpretability
of what they call blackbox classifiers
so unfortunately this is only available
for classifiers I'm going to put that
big disclaimer first so you can't use
this with anything other than
classifiers but what they were able to
show and this is a screenshot from there
O'Reilly blog post about it is they were
taking images they took a CNN and what
they were able to show is okay this
image is classified as a tree frog then
they built what they called perturbed
instances which is essentially clusters
of pixels with these perturbed instances
they then try to define the minimal
cluster of pixels that could achieve the
maximum probability so they put it
through some regression of course and
then we have the final explanation and
in this explanation we can see ok the
face of the tree frog is what this
locally and this is the local optimal
minimum solution so how does it work in
a broader sense the researchers also
included this image which I feel like
was useful for understanding the overall
concept of what they're trying to do and
perhaps useful in the sense that if
you're a researcher in this space maybe
this can inspire you to work on
something other than just classification
here we have a function it is our
classifier we have red and blue so we
only have two classes and we can see
that it's not a linear explanation that
there's no global explanation that can
work for us we take the red X and we say
why does the red X you know why is it
classified as red and what we can do is
by taking different samples around it or
in the case of their model actually take
samples from it and determine
okay what is the derivative at this
location now this is a local explanation
it only works for potentially even that
red X depending on the location of that
red X but what it can do is it can allow
us to explain these local minimums right
and when we're able to explain at least
the local explanations that gives us a
starting place it gives us something
intuitively that we can understand that
we can look at and that we can perhaps
give to others without of course chart
and show them okay this is why the model
has learned this or this is what the
network has learned within this specific
case
so beyond lime there's actually some
other open source Python libraries for
this and one of them is li5 and ela five
is after the famous internet meme of
explain to me like I'm five and what Li
five does is it gives you the ability to
run text classification now lime does as
well they're a bit of a competition in
that space but Li five also plugs into
line so Li five is a great starting
place and here is an example from the
twenty newsgroups data set so it was
trained classic twenty twenty newsgroups
data set and its goal is to classify the
text what Li five gives you is it's
going to go through a set of samplers
and it's going to go through five
thousand samples of different
tokenization so here you have in the
background what's running is you have
this text is going to create 5,000
samples of this text and then it's going
to compute in different ways of
tokenizing and it's going to use the
same tokens but it's going to show
different tokens to the model and it's
going to try to find the combination
that increases or decreases the
probability of it being classified as
medical text and while we can see is the
tokens that have contributed the most
are in the darker green and the tokens
that have detracted the most are in the
darker red and so we can see kidney
stones medication pain these make sense
to us one thing that didn't make sense
to me is why x-ray seems to be in red
and I believe my intuition and looking
at it is I can see X is highlighted the
hyphen is not so perhaps it's removed
during tokenization and the Ray is
highlighted strongly and for me the
first question that I had is how did
they choose tokenization a
pre-processing on this text and could we
perhaps find a better way to do so
so that x-ray is in green as I believe
it probably should be so what I would
say is that just from me looking at
their tutorial and walkthrough I was
like ah this could be perhaps something
that we could use a character RNN for or
that we could use a different type of
tokenization and we could compare our
models and perhaps improve or generalize
our model further by actually looking at
the explanations and saying as a human
with my common sense this doesn't make
sense to me so I think explanations can
work not only to help create
explanations for the end user but also
create explanations for yourself where
you can further enhance your model given
the feedback li5 also works with XG
boost and who here is working with X
jeebus who here is working with XG boost
on kaggle only okay
I think there's XG booths talk which I'm
pretty excited to go to I think XP
boosts is very hyper cool right now and
I want to be with the cool kids so I'm
gonna learn all about X cheapest so X G
boost though is a bit difficult to
interpret because of the way that the
weights change with the residuals it can
be difficult to interpret and so one
thing that yel i5 gives you is a
visualization of your weights
this is of course pretty simple here
when we use the Titanic data set and we
do know future engineering it can be
pretty easy to say oh yeah if you're a
woman you probably survived and if
you're in the third class you probably
died but this is really this is a toy
example right our Titanic data set is
only here as a toy example we can also
see that you know although this is
useful what are the weights what does
the contribute contribution of the
weights actually mean this doesn't
necessarily give me as a human a big
intuition other than you know the simple
variants that we can see it doesn't give
me a good intuition of what this
actually means and I would say that this
is more of a critique of X G boost as a
model and also how we can discuss and
decide better ways that we can interpret
this type of data they go on in their
tutorial to extract a few different
features for name name ending a few
things like that so it's worth breeding
through because there is some neat
things that you can do with the e li5
library moving beyond simple machine
learning models and into neural networks
they're tremendously difficult to
explain one shining light in that is
attention based networks so I don't know
if you've been reading or using
attention base RN ends but there a way
that we can more easily introspect what
the model has learned and this is
because attention base RN ends allow us
to see what's essentially being kept in
RAM right and if we could check what's
being kept in memory we can start to say
ah the model has focused on this the
model has retained that and so forth
there's a really interesting paper or
there's many many interesting papers
about attention base are dense but one
one that I felt was particularly
demonstrative of interpretability and
introspection was this show attend tell
which is a neural image caption our Erin
and in their paper they also shared some
interesting mistakes and they were able
to take a look at mistakes that their
model made and they were able to show
where the network was focused what was
held in memory at the point in time that
had generated the text for the caption
and here we can see we have I don't know
if it's easy to discern but we have two
giraffes standing and when the neural
network was focused on the two giraffes
standing there it saw a bird and it
classified a woman who is speaking and
she has a logo on her sweatshirt it
classified the logo as a clock and let's
just say we might have some issues with
violinists and this indeed helps us
train but our models when we can
understand the areas that the network is
having a problem with we can think of
better training samples we can think of
adversarial examples that might help
improve our model and so I would say
that particularly in the case of our own
ends one easy way to start saying Ah
this is how it's being tricked is by
using an intention based one where you
can actually see what's being accessed
in memory and what's being stored over
time and there's also some interesting
work on attention based NLP models so I
can also share more research with you if
you're intrigued by this because for me
this was quite interesting to take a
look at moving also back into the NLP
world there is a great paper and also an
open-source Python library from the
rationalizing neural predictions paper
in this set of researchers they took on
a series of common NLP tasks of which
one is multi aspect sentiment
so this is the ability to look at a
review and say these parts of the review
tell me about this aspects these parts
of the review tell me about this other
aspect and they use the famous beer
reviews data set so if you like beer
this is a very fun - data set to play
with even if you don't like beer because
it's very properly labeled and it's nice
to have good labels for something like
multi aspects sentiment analysis but
what they were able to do is they were
able to build what they call a generator
and encoder and with this generator
encoder not dissimilar to other
generators and encoders you might use
with rnns or other deep learning
frameworks they wanted to generate the
smallest explainable parts of text and
then encode them and run the prediction
or the predicted score for that aspect
on them then they were able to use this
to find the phrases and they had
optimized actually for phrases so they
optimized for connected speech rather
than disparate tokens and what they were
able to show is some really interesting
stuff so they could say the aroma is
kind of bubblegum like and grainy and
out of the whole review this is the most
important text for the two stars now to
human this is like Katherine this is not
very impressive I could read this and
highlight this in five seconds and yes
indeed the beer data set really lends
itself to this and we can talk about all
sorts of problems of sentiment analysis
I have lots of opinions on this but the
point is is that we're starting to
perhaps create things that can create
small explanations small rationales as
they call them and we can start to see
if our network is making sense or
perhaps it has learned a few key words
or somebody's name or something else and
we can start to debug why it won't
generalize or why it might not be
converging and so forth and finally we
have the famous or historical examples
which are primarily rule and probability
based systems so I'm really excited that
probabilistic programming is back in
fashion I think there's a few
there are probability experts in the
room that are probably pretty excited
about this too it seems that probability
is again the new hotness or maybe has
always been hot but people are talking
about it more anyways when we use rule
and probability based decision systems
these are pretty easy to explain when we
use statistical models and they make
sense of our data and they're simple
then we can easily share them with say a
doctor and we can say hey you can take a
look at this rule set which is a
decision list using Bayesian analysis
was this decision list that was
developed with the breast cancer data
set and as a doctor you could think they
can read this they can reason with it
perhaps they can even disagree with it
in a meaningful way so perhaps we don't
see here we don't have genetic
information about if the gene that has
been linked to breast cancer is there so
if they're perhaps using that as an
indicator maybe they're making a
different decision but they can actually
decide that as an area expert rather
than just say trust this machine the
machine will tell you how to do your job
and I think that that level of
transparency particularly in the highly
regulated industries is essential and
especially when we're talking about law
we're talking about people's lives we're
talking about banking we're talking
about their their money their ability to
get a loan their ability to own house
their ability to do normal things in
their life and we're talking about
medicine I don't necessarily want my
doctor to have a black box model that it
feeds my data and then it goes mine some
word vectors and then it tells me oh
you're pregnant or something I don't
necessarily want that to be my future
life so I would like us also to think
about these rule and probability based
systems and I'm not saying stop the
research for Jane stop the work we're
doing I think we can do both
simultaneously
I think we can find new really cool ways
to use neural networks and then we can
try to find ways to simplify what we've
learned from the neural network to
create probability based systems and I I
don't see these as massively divergent
of course are going to be done by
different researchers but I also
think that there's a lot of interesting
work happening in Bayesian neural
networks and other things which might
help give us insight or also in sparse
vector parameter ization that might give
us the ability to have better insight
into what is in our data and what these
deep learning networks have learned so
what problems are still unsolved
as I'm sure if you're a machine learning
practitioner you're like Katherine you
haven't talked about a million things
yes I haven't and I'm sorry for that now
we'll talk about all of the problems
interpret E is still a really really
broad research space and there's many
many problems so if you're a student in
this room and you're like I don't know
what I'll do my thesis on please for for
the hope of all of us do it on
interpretability or something related to
interpretability here is a screen grab
from ml for a which is an open source
book for artists and it tries to teach
artists how to use machine learning
particularly of course generative out of
adversarial networks to do really cool
stuff with art and what they use is they
use the CIF AR model and they can show
all of these pretty little images and
then the probability that there's an
airplane there or that there's a bird
there it I mean as an artist you're
probably like oh wow this is really
pretty and then as somebody who's trying
to interpret networks you're like what
is going on I cannot see filter five has
an airplane evidently I don't see it I
guess maybe blue because the sky these
are the types of inferences that we have
to make and we use our human based
pattern matching to find patterns for
perhaps there actually are not and this
is a problem that we have with
interpretability especially if neural
networks is we take time to introspect
them we look at each of the layers that
particularly for visual models but now
also somewhat for language based models
and we say yeah I think it's learned
something there how much of that can we
actually mathematically prove and how
much is us just finding patterns because
as what we're good at I leave that for
debate
another big problem in interpretability
is multi-dimensional projections so
often we're working in a space with 300
to 500 even more dimensions and our
feeble little human brains are like what
is going on so when we think about these
multi-dimensional things particularly
let's say in NLP we try to find ways to
project them into a space we can
understand - or 3d right and this is a
screenshot from my co-organizer PI data
Berlin Mattie Lyra and he will very soon
be finishing his doctorate in topic
modeling and he gave a really great talk
at PI data Berlin this year on
understanding topic modeling and he was
using P COA which is very similar to PCA
and he was also using metric
multidimensional s and i'll justsee say
p coa
and mmds from here on forward and these
are ways that you can take these topic
models and you can project them into a
two dimensional space so you can analyze
is this a good number of groups is this
a good number of topics is my model
working to find topics for your text and
here on the Left we have P Co a and he's
highlighted group topic number 10 in
topic number 15 and we can see they're
quite close together and also that quite
a lot of the topics are clustered close
together and then on the right we see
mmds this is the same data set and they
are nearly opposite ends of our metric
space Y and this is simply because of
the projection that we use and the
parameters that we use with our
projection but how can we actually make
sense of this as humans if we're using
these projections to make sense and we
change the algorithm slightly or we
change the parameter slightly and we get
a completely different projection how
can we then say that this projection is
a good explanation I don't think we can
say I think that this is still an open
area of research and I think that
depending on your understanding of the
under
data you can probably justify the left
or the right diagram but I think if
you're just saying oh yeah I know I'm
just gonna use T Snee and it makes sense
and look let's move on that perhaps
there's more to the problem than simply
using a multi-dimensional projection
into a space that we can understand also
labeling is hard and sampling is hard
and if we'll talk about each
individually the comic is a little bit
more about labeling but I'll tie it into
sampling and I'll give you a moment to
read it this is like Calvin and Hobbes
and yeah I mean depending on where your
data is coming from and who's labeled it
and how many mechanical Turks were used
and how much instruction they were given
before they were mechanical turk in your
data this could be a problem for you
right and hopefully you're doing some
normalization or regularization or
you're using some sort of scalars so you
perhaps find this outlier or you remove
it in some way shape or form but my
warning here is just that these things
can hide in plain sight
and depending also on your normalization
used they can just become another data
point that supposedly makes sense then
when say you're using sampling and
you're saying okay I'm going to I'm
going to select some samples maybe I'm
going to select some samples that
confuse the model and then I'm going to
select some samples that are really
average of the model that explained the
the normal occurrences you might select
this or you might select something like
it or you might leave it out and either
way you you're making some sort of
conclusion about your model and what
your model has learned and how your
model behaves based on a sample and
sampling is hard we know this sampling
is hard it is still an area of open
research hundreds of years after people
first started talking about it so I
think sampling is really difficult to
when we think about
ability and how can we choose a good
representative sample that we can use
for good explanations and poor
explanations and there's a few good
papers on this and some of them have
libraries attached I'll be writing up a
lot much longer blog post of all of my
research on this with a bunch of links
for you if you're interested and cadwal
was already mentioned but I say that I
feel like we're in a phase of what I
call Calif occation and I feel like the
more and more I talk with people in the
space particularly those that are avid
cacklers I have nothing against cackle I
think it's fun to play games and it's
fun to gamify hard problems and cool if
you can make money off of kaggle so be
it
but I would say that Calif ocation is
also bringing us the death by 1000
models and it seems I found this quote
for looking around on good quotes about
kaggle and ensembl entitles as part of
kaggle 101 if you don't do it you're at
a disadvantage now should you do it in a
business environment that's a very
different question but in Kaggle you
should and this is a case right when you
look at the top cago models now
sometimes they're averaged across 10,000
different models 1000 models at least
beyond that there's been a bunch of
tuning of parameters there's been also
over-engineering I would say of features
everybody's using polynomials and and so
forth and that's great that's fine but
my fear is that when Kaggle bleeds over
into our daily decisions when we start
to say I don't know I was got you know
top top 30% in the last competition I
think I'll try some of this at work and
my my fear for this is we definitely
lose interpretability right we can't
interpret ensemble models especially as
humans even if we can interpret them
mathematically as humans being able to
explain an ensemble and to be able to
explain let's say the average weights
across the ensemble is really difficult
for us to do in a meaningful
away and so I don't want to I don't want
people to stop haggling I think it's fun
but what I do want to have is better
conversations in the workspace of when
these types of ensemble models have a
place and perhaps when interpretability
or knowing and understanding what your
model has learned is more key speaking
of which I will have a blog series based
on taking winning Kaggle models trying
to interpret them and then trying to
slowly break them down into something
that you actually can interpret and in
doing so I've been working with some of
the winners of the kaggle house price
data set and I decided I'll just put it
into a li 5 and see what happens right
like what could go wrong but um an X 7 X
7 is the worst you guys it's really
awful X 7 X 4 7 8 7 that's really going
to make your house price quite a bit
higher and the problem here is that yes
we're using polynomial features and I
think for coggle that's fine but if this
is in a model that you're actually
trying to explain or use at work and say
what has your model learned we are so
far from any meaningful feature that we
would have to basically restart from
scratch or completely reverse engineer
what has occurred with these over I
would say over engineered features so
for a competition great fun and for real
life in the sense of hey I need to
explain to my co-workers or to my boss
or to the end user or to the area expert
I need to explain what my model has
learned this makes no sense to human so
perhaps now you're inspired and we're
like how can we help well there's
clearly a lot of areas that are open I
hope you're inspired I hope you're not
depressed if you're also not like I
don't care I like cattle so the first
thing is cultural so I feel like this is
both a cultural as we've talked about
and a technical problem
and the cultural things we can do I
think are to teach practice and preach
interpretability again I am NOT anti
other ways of doing things but I do
think that if we're having more
conversations about interpretability
this can benefit us as a community
so why not just you already have the ROC
curve or whatever else you're showing to
be like I'm the smartest model ever
that's been built why not also include a
section on interpretability in your
curriculum or your blog posts or your
talks just one short one it could be hey
I found out that I couldn't interpret
this model but if this becomes more of a
norm at least we're having the
conversation at least we're starting to
understand what is interpretable and
what isn't if you're researcher or you
work at a cool research lab if you have
access to TP use and so forth then work
on difficult problems in the
interpretative space and share your
results come give this keynote next year
I don't want to be talking I want to
listen to somebody who's researching on
this space add sample explanations and
introspection of your models or
architecture into your daily workflow
and I put daily there but really what I
mean is your average workflow that you
do when you begin a machine learning
problem and perhaps you're doing some
exploration I want at some stage there
to be an interpretor introspection step
or at least a sample explanation so
choose a subset and try to explain them
and if you work this into your daily
workflow I think not only will the tools
grow and change but that we can help
figure out better open source ways to
solve these problems and finally talk
with your colleagues and peers so I hope
to have many conversations I will be
here all day it's day and tomorrow and I
hope to chat with you if you're working
in the space or if you're intrigued by
the space but I also mainly want you to
chat with one another and chat with
other researchers finally the technical
aspects what can we do technically and I
think that we can embrace more
interpretable model engineering so when
you're doing feature engineering ask
yourself am I doing the Kaggle thing
again
and if the answer is yes perhaps think
do I actually need to do the kaggle
thing right now or can I perhaps find a
way that is slightly more interpretable
challenge yourself to build the MVP of
models and I mean the minimal viable
model and what I mean by that is start
off simple start off basic check your
interpretability
and your accuracy then further build and
develop and check your interpret ability
and your accuracy again and see where it
breaks see where your interpretability
breaks and let's say your accurate
accuracy becomes amazing then at least
you know the breaking point of whatever
model or architecture you're using and
finally I think that we really need to
begin especially as an open source
community figure out how do we measure
interpret ability and there's actually
quite a lot of research on this already
there's quite a lot of algorithms that
are available already on this so how can
we then work this metric or measurement
into our daily work so we can say yeah
my accuracy is here my f1 score is this
and my recall is so and so and my
interpret ability is this and I think
that this would be really powerful
because then it's something that we can
optimize and we seem to be very good at
optimizing things so I would appreciate
if we can also try to optimize for
interpretability so I want to say thanks
so much again and thank you for taking
time to listen to me today and I really
hope that we can have further
conversations if you want questions I
don't know if we have time now but you
can always find me later I'm at cage I'm
on Twitter
I'm at Kay honest and calm and also I
will be posting a lot of longer thoughts
on this and a bunch of research you can
read and Python libraries you can play
with by the end of it today I promise
it's not up yet but by the end of today
so thank you so much
[Applause]
okay thanks so much Katrina I think we
can do a Q&A session drinking coffee so
you can find Katrin over there are going
to join the after party tonight and stay
tomorrow
you